what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation I am about to show you
guys my reaction first time watching for
the movie Moana spoiler alert uh wow
what an incredibly moving film before I
show you guys that couple things leave a
like you know you know how much I love
when you leave a like and of course if
you want to catch our full-length
Reaction watch along that is available
for our super sexy rejects over at our
patreon page we cover a whole bunch of
stuff exclusively over there and all you
know reaction watches that you need you
know just that your support does mean
the world I really wanted to hop on here
to tell you that we have partnered up
with the channel geek that's g-i-q-u-e
currently I have an exclusive video over
there koi has two exclusive videos over
there I do happen to have a personal
relationship with one of the main people
who's running it so yeah this is
something that is very meaningful to me
so what geek mainly does is provide
these one minute character origin
stories and other pop culture content
from a wide variety of creators I
genuinely believe it's a wonderful up
and coming channel for a variety of
reasons one of them being not only is it
a great place to get some extra geek and
nerdy content if you you yourself are a
Creator hoping to make some extra bucks
or get some exposure you can join the
geek community and possibly get paid to
produce a one minute short yourself you
can pause this video right now check out
one of our videos or you can just wait
after the reaction and go ahead and
check it out koi did An Origin story on
Red Hood and Spider-Man 299 I did a very
different type on Nightwing but it
really mean the world if you guys could
subscribe to them because over here at
real rejects we want to help get the
spotlight on them with what they're
developing over there I really do think
it's a great communal experience and
something that is kind of necessitated
on a platform like this which can often
feel like more competitive instead of
community it's just a solid place to get
some extra nerdy content and to also
help up and coming creators absolutely
thrilled to be partnering with them now
let's get on to watching Moana
[Music]
a mother Island emerged
art held the greatest power ever known
he could create life itself
this is cool
in time some began to seek if it is hard
they believed if they could possess it
the great power of creation would be
theirs of course
he was a demigod of the Wind and Sea
he was a warrior
a trickster and look how good this looks
and his name
was Maui Maui
but without her heart te fiti began to
crumble giving birth to a terrible
Darkness
this is the one I I heard Dwayne Johnson
this is when doing Johnson plays right
Maui tried to escape but was confronted
by another who sought the heart
holy God a demon of Earth and fire wow
[Music]
ooh chills guys whoa what an opening
magical fish
and the Heart of te fiti were lost to
the Sea the Peril here the heart will be
found by someone who will Journey beyond
our reef and save us all ho ho ho thank
you mother that's enough
there are no monsters
wow look at that animation my God
so real
oh
how ethereal
foreign
do you have any comprehension of what's
going on right now
[Music]
[Music]
there you are Moana what are you doing
you scared me
[Music]
dude sounds like Boba Fett is it is it
tomorrow worse it sounds like him
wanna
make way make way more night's time you
knew the village
all you need
oh this is neat it's cool to see a movie
about some Pacific Islanders uh
Polynesian culture
[Music]
so adorable
[Music]
what we need
what a great play on words there
I think I'm crazy or say that I drift
too far but once you know what you like
well there you are good Rhymes in here
[Music]
interesting it's like a journey about
learning to appreciate what you
currently have
while also accepting that you want
Adventure as well as
I am hooked I'm curious about that
chicken eating the rock I mean he seems
to lack the basic intelligence required
for pretty much everything
sometimes our strengths lie beneath the
surface oh my God
[Laughter]
[Music]
one room an old rule when there were
fish a rule that keeps us safe instead
of endangering our people so you can run
right back to the water
oh
he was you he took a canoe morning
he crossed the reef
he found an unforgiving sea his best
friend begged to be on that boat
ah
[Music]
this one was making me want to sail
animal
s
delicious inspiring
[Music]
man I've really become a sensitive guy
[Music]
I love hello guys so much so cute
there's more fish Beyond The Reef
damn this movie looks so beautiful
I cannot get over it not so bad
no
[Music]
ouch ouch
oh
[Music]
good thing those waters are clear she
could find a rock yeah this movie does a
great job on setting up the Peril I love
this movie
what's in there the answer to the
question you keep asking yourself
who are you meant to be ban the drum
and find
Bang the Drum
[Music]
and Maui
I know really banging I put some rhythm
in there come on Moana
foreign
what is happening right now
[Music]
is she seeing all this
oh my God you gotta go out there Moana
oh so beautiful so beautiful
oh that's your your true roots
you're meant to explore Moana when he
stole from the mother Island Darkness
fell
picker awoke to protect our people the
ancient Chiefs forbid for him such a
good lore building cool Universe one day
someone will Journey beyond our Reef
touristy you know what you gotta do
Moana the ocean chose you
uh-huh
the news we can take them fine Maui make
him restore the heart we were voyagers
we can Voyage again
don't know how to introduce the subject
to you more
what
grandma
oh you will board my boat sail across
the sea
the heart of this
I can't believe you oh this is so sad
[Music]
Let Her Go
yeah I swear I do not come on here did
you cry Jesus Christ
[Laughter]
sail Moana
[Music]
past the roof
foreign
the chicken
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yikes
I get a little help
oh not cool
this is a horror movie
wow appreciate that when it goes dark
with its visuals it really commits to it
I said how
not coming
fish peeing you all day Maui
Maui
I am Moana of boat mode
a boat the gods have given me
Maui shapeshifter demigod of the Wind
and Sea I am one hero of men hero of men
I interrupted from the top hero of men
go
I'm here cause you stole the heart of
tefiti sail across the sea and put it
back that got stuck here for a thousand
years trying to get the heart as a gift
for you Mortals so you could have the
power to create life itself huh believe
you were trying to say is thank you
thank you you're welcome no no no I see
what's happening yeah
know it's a lot the hair the bar
what can I say except you're welcome oh
I've heard some of this I think I've
heard this song before
Oh this is where it's from
I don't think I ever paid attention to
the lyrics before
cool
that's our creative
wow look at that that is so great so
much culture influencing here
[Laughter]
and thank you that is messed up
whoa you're a strong one Moana oh no no
no don't look at me like that it's a
beautiful cave she's gonna love it
[Music]
ouch
enjoy the island Maui
hey you have to put back the heart
ocean help her out you will restore the
heart
all right I'm out
if you don't put it away bad things are
going to come for it Comfort this
You Are Gonna Get Us killed no I'm gonna
get a city so so you can put it back
welcome
what was that
kakamora Coco what murdering Little
Pirates what wonder what they're here
for
oh my God
they're kind of cute
thank you
holy crap I mean they're still kind of
cute you
[Music]
[Music]
this is wildly inventive
magic hook no magic power
that is awesome
no
[Applause]
awesome they're just gonna kill you
[Music]
coconuts
oh yes yes look at Rico
thank you
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you got to go through a whole lotion of
bad not to mention tekka
Lava Monster oh yes you'd be a hero I am
a hero me
me were now you're just just the guy who
sold
that is true put this back
save the world you'd beat everyone's
hero you're so smart Moana
the score and the musical numbers are so
good I
called wayfinding Princess it's seeing
where you're going going in your mind
knowing where you are by knowing where
you've been I'm not a princess
I'm the daughter of the chief
considered a Disney princess
you're measuring the Stars not giving
the sky a high five if the current's
warm you're going the right way
[Music]
wait
Karma
oh gross gross
oh no this isn't real
come on
oh my God they're getting Thanos
and he lives up there
that's just the entrance to
um
of monsters
oh this is gonna be cool
damn the way they flesh out the
environment man like all the elements
and stuff it's beautiful
hahaha
go
oh how neat they're gonna go to talocon
okay let's get my hook
yo whoa what the hell oh my God that is
scary oh yeah
yeah
realm of monsters indeed I hear why this
movie is PG now
[Music]
holy crap
that was kind of scary
[Music]
what have we here oh God they are funny
looking little things aren't you don't
that's my grandma there's my grandma I
ate my grandma and it took a week cause
he was absolutely humongous
[Laughter]
that's your main uh Clement
I was a tribe Little Crab once now I
know I can be happy as a clam because
I'm beautiful baby
woman's neck just a sec don't you know
Fisher Dum Dums
beginners I love the direction of these
musical numbers
[Music]
still a little rusty
[Music]
[Laughter]
whoa
you so prepare your final play I love
the colors man
[Music]
damn
that's great camera work in this the
heart
you can't run from me oh you can you
keep surprising me
where is it where is it we gotta go
what about the heart I think it happened
I've got a better one wait a minute
I see she's taking a barnacle and she's
covered it in bioluminescent algae
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey hey
did you like the song I did I thought
the song was great you did me a solid
but you also almost died and I couldn't
even beat the dumb crab so chances of
beating Taka
bubkus we're never making it to defeat
you see you're warmed up again man
do you get your tattoos they show up
when I earn them what's that for that's
uh man's discovery of Nunya what's nanya
Nunya business
oh I wasn't born a demigod
I had human parents
took one look and
and decided
they did not want me no I was found by
the Gods
they gave me the hook and back to the
humans I went
I gave them Islands fire coconuts
oh he's been searching for Love from his
parents his whole time huh maybe the
gods found you forever
maybe the ocean brought you to them
because it saw someone who is worthy of
being saved you're damn right
hey that's cool they can Inspire each
other
it's not my place to talk about female
empowerment but I feel like this is a
pretty empowering female character
look at you go Maui I think I'd be
looking for a curly-haired non-princess
to start that again that is literally
the nicest thing you've ever said to me
probably should have saved it for
activity
just what
leave you have officially delivered Maui
across the Great Sea
wow
you're like how horrified this is
water is its weakness
we won't make it yes we will turn around
oh Moana stop
Jesus
Maui
oh no Maui you have to restore the heart
without my hook I am nothing that's not
true without my hook I am nothing
sure nothing without the suit you
shouldn't have to suit at all I'm not
killing myself so you could prove you're
something you're not
chose wrong
oh that's messed up
[Music]
oh no the ocean's just gonna wait
the right tattoo
is she dead they're from voyagers who
found their way across the world
they called me
that's great
it's a great story of self-discovery man
[Music]
yeah you are
you little Voyager
go kick that
thing zest whatever that
[Music]
is so cool I love this design
[Music]
that's awesome using the Embrace of
being a Voyager
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
oh that's cool
whoa oh you little badass
that's scary
[Music]
no what
[Music]
hey I got your back Chosen One
go save the world
thank you
this is so cool
I'm so happy right now
[Music]
oh smart
[Music]
man look how amazing that looks
thank you
[Music]
it's like some God of War [ __ ] man
[Music]
oh wow use your last hit
[Music]
whoa
no
how
oh
let her come to me
just chills
everywhere right now laughs
[Music]
across the horizon to find you
this is so beautiful
oh it's just a torture
[Music]
you
you know you who you are wow
what is this movie
oh my goodness
whoa
this is this is insane
whenever it releases in the theaters I'm
going
hmm the chicken lives
I'm sorry about your hook well I'm Maui
what I did was
wrong
I'm sorry
no way
that's cool he got to uh
you gotta grow and accept who he is
before he even got that
huh
this movie is beautiful
absolutely beautiful
this would be such a cool video game
you could come with us you know my
people are going to need a
master wayfinder
they already have one
goddamn right they do
[Music]
hahaha
there goes anyway
God from beginning to end this
animation's been so striking it
communicates so much emotion
[Music]
it's kidding me man
[Music]
I may have gone a little ways past the
reef
it suits you
[Music]
these are happy tears
foreign
[Music]
they're all voyaging look at them voyage
every sign
wow that was beautiful
dude dudes did this
it's probably the most surprising part
of this
yeah it lines up pretty well actually uh
yeah that was a
absolutely uh wait to see there's a
post-currency that's absolutely
mesmerizing movie I mean story about
self-discovery exploring different
cultures like Polynesian culture it
wasn't like inspiring and uplifting and
and felt like and empowering as a 32
year old man I was empowered by the
Journey of Moana and the story of
acceptance of where you are lineage and
what you want to set out to do as well
it was just so gorgeous I really
respected it a lot you know I I like the
Disney I'm obviously playing some catch
up here uh in front of you guys on the
channel
but I was always under the impression
model like just another Disney princess
character but she's so much she's like
kind of not you know it's like just
because she's a female who we categorize
her as Disney princess but she even says
and here she blatantly States I'm not a
princess there's something that's so
strong and feels authentic and nuanced
well realized and lived in about her
character assertive determined flawed
but
uh strong at the same time you know
Wayne Johnson is bow we also did an
excellent job with his performance it is
timora Morrison okay is this the second
I heard of like sounds like Boba Fett
the way how Dwayne Johnson brought this
character to life because you know you
could feel a lot of that like
chauvinistic this almost veneer of
machismo that this man put on there was
something that you could feel this like
pain underneath it all and I like the
fleshing out of the characters this guy
who really just wanted validation and to
be loved and connected with people they
managed to make him relatable like
instead of making him to relate to
another Disney character like a Gaston
that wasn't him he was someone who again
was also flawed and actually had well
like good intentions but made mistakes
you know repercussions happen but it was
also such a character journey and I love
the dovetail of how
both these individuals
while sort of Judge for being who they
really are aspects of them that are
loved and accepted but what I thought
was cool about the movie too with with
these with their two titular characters
was that who they really were was a part
of them was not truly accepted by others
but they had to learn to accept that
about themselves first you know so it is
a story of self-discovery and
self-acceptance it's just a great
message overall for people but the songs
too were so well done uh I I think that
you know you hear a little Manuel
Miranda in the crash like that lines up
because I was noticing like the Rhymes
are really really cool but it wasn't
like rap heavy but there's still some
really cool Rhymes that they had and I
thought they had so much personality and
life and humor and it was also so moving
and sweeping and I kept saying it
throughout the the animation uh it had
this great ethereal quality that really
fleshed out the tone and this mood this
atmosphere to life that I I was so swept
up in I found it so powerful like the
animation itself was was its character
it was a character in and of itself uh
throughout the whole film The Ocean
while there was that Motif with the the
when the ocean pops up to talk to Moana
and sometimes carry her uh back onto the
canoe the ocean itself was a character
it breeds such life like this movie had
such fast rich life to it from beginning
to end with the culture uh influenced
throughout you know and I think like the
different kinds of creatures that we saw
felt like something out of like an epic
PS5 video game to be the way they
handled the Peril and and at times like
the they needed some of that horror
animation to really strike a chord
that way the the more joyous light Parts
uh really shine through as well you know
you need that balance and I feel like
sometimes these animated movies you know
more so with like the Disney animated
movies it can be a little bit timid now
to go down that realm so I appreciate it
when you did see like certain moments
that were like that is truly scary when
they countered it like with a taka
character when they countered it with
seeing like when she's like beautiful
big and green and boisterous like and
and one with the nature
you needed that effect of like all the
lava and the tortured Soul like there
was so much
Humanity infused and so much emotion
there was like depth to
the designs of the characters even in
the big Larger than Life creatures like
with the crab guy it was so funny like
that that's got to be Jermaine Clement
recognize his voice uh with the crowd
weather was there was so much expression
brought to life
physically but internally I really feel
like the way they went about with
animating their characters it was always
rooted in some kind of emotional core
rather than just going we got to make
this look cool it was rooted in some way
of what is the best way to enhance the
experience of it on an emotional way
where we can connect to it because they
did such a great job with the eyes
um but the body language too was was
something that I was really noticing in
this film like the body language of
these characters even the bigger
creatures like to call like them and the
crab creature's name but I like the crab
teacher but even even the little Pirates
the body language so well done
shiny I'm so shiny
didn't help me though did it
still upside down here just need a
little push
[Laughter]
can we be real if my name was Sebastian
and I had a cool Jamaican accent it
totally helped me you would you know you
would
I was funny
worth it sticking around we're sticking
around but anyway yeah I mean I I love
that the movie was also like uh
like there's a story about like
conquering
something like you know find Maui and
and and say this thing to to Maui when
you find him but you know like the whole
goal is to heal her Village and the
problems that it's encountering in the
movies really about healing and I I love
that that the film is ultimately about
healing and when you get to the end even
with the car she doesn't try to strike
like you think it's leading to like
striking them down and defeating like oh
you use the water against the car really
it's like the objective that you have to
do in order to accomplish is to heal the
villages you got to heal to con I
thought that was such a beautiful
message as well you know like the the
way to resolve is the path of compassion
I think there's a lot there's a lot of
beautiful displays of
compassion throughout this entire movie
like she's a very compassionate
character and I love that about her I
love the animals a lot
super like the the chicken was was the
MVP of the movie to me in so many ways
that the chicken was amazing
I also noticed there's no love interest
in this film
uh which is actually refreshing we're
really making or not a Disney princess
character like it's a story just about
friendship and family
and
it seemed like it could have gone down
this route that could have been like
kind of cliche of like my family doesn't
get me and I gotta kind of go against
what my family thinks about me and do it
and while there's a like a little
quality about that it it really is a
a story that feels respectful of towards
your elders you know and and I think she
I think the movie really nailed that as
well like she is very loving towards her
family
and so much so to the point of bringing
this movie full circle with going to the
lineage of the family being voyagers and
I love how that wraps around and becomes
this massive influence and someone who's
going to become the new Chief you got to
have this display of new kinds of
leadership abilities and ways of moving
you know the family forward
and I I thought that was beautiful
aspect to the movie as well wrapping it
around full circle with the Voyager
quality but also you know
being respectful and and connective with
the family as opposed to going down this
route of like she's a teenage girl and
she's going to rebel against her family
they didn't do that storyline like it
never felt ingrained in being a
rebellious kid which is where I thought
the movie was setting it up to go but it
didn't quite do that it was just the
right it was just following her heart of
what she knew what was right and what
was best for her family so it was about
again about healing and learning about
yourself along the way and also learning
uh you know a cool skill with being a
wayfinder uh I like that in order for
her to accomplish her goal she really
had to learn something along the way
like a physical set of skills and of
course being you know taught by Maui but
I I also really loved how that was put
throughout like it was it was a beat
that was constantly being explored
throughout the movie because
by the time she she has to learn us I
really don't feel like when it comes to
these Princess Characters like she's not
even a princess but I really feel like
when it comes to these kind of
characters they normally don't have
something like that and I think that was
a really cool objective that they put in
front of her so she's learning about
herself she's learning a physical skill
I think there's just a lot of great
learning throughout it and it feels like
it's
I imagine I'm curious what the research
was on this movie with everything they
wanted to infuse into here because
there's so many themes that are so
beautiful throughout but also it's like
a tone poem happening with its
environment hitting you in the fields
throughout and just it's Landscapes and
elements that are so wonderfully woven
in but yeah guys I thought it was uh I
thought it was an amazing movie and I'm
glad I watched it and uh thank you guys
for being here with me on this journey I
thought it was excellent everything all
around I thought it was an excellent
excellent movie
so thank you be sure to leave a like
subscribe you can check us on patreon
and let's send this with a
caldorian dude it's good to see you
again how have you been I'm actually
going to be at this moment of this video
going up I'm in Colorado your home state
right now
getting hitched so caldorian I haven't
heard from you in a while I hope
everything is going good and the Native
American part of your life and I want to
say that the conversations we've had in
the past have been a wonderful gift
that's being Christmas and the time of
giving I want to say that you've gifted
us along the way with not just a
wonderful pledge but also uh with being
vulnerable and sharing so much about
your life and who you are with us and I
know there's some tough bouts that you
had to go through but you've always been
someone with a after watching a movie
that's so much about compassion and love
it's great to know someone like you who
is so full of compassion so full of love
so-called dorians it's great to see your
name up here again but uh I hope that
you're able to have a wonderful
Christmas and and have a fantastic
celebration for the holidays because
there's anyone who deserves it it's you
you're so full of generosity in your
heart and in every way you communicate
even when you're stressed out or in a
negative or bad mood it's never to the
point where I feel like you're you know
bringing me down in any way because you
you just have that like loving caring
quality always omitted so thank you for
being you and thank you for being part
of our patreon and thank you for always
being like one of our top supporters
buddy uh hope you have a Merry Christmas
and a Happy New Year and what are your
plans for the New Year let me know man I
want to know I want to know what crazy
goals you got in mind because you are an
ambitious creative fella and I want to
see you knock some [ __ ] out so be well
buddy thank you
[Music]